♪
♪.
JASON: WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW" A BALTIMORE TEACHER
HOW SHE CAN INDOCTRINATING KIDS
ON TIKTOK.
THE TEACHER JOKED SHE WAS FIRED
AND THEN SAID PUT THE TAXES IN
THE BAG.
IN NEW YORK CITY THE MAN WAS
ARRESTED FOR PUNCHING A POLICE
OFFICER AFTER CONFRONTING
PROTESTERS OF DRAG QUEEN STORY
HOUR AT A PUBLIC LIBRARY.
CONSERVATIVE FAITH-BASED KIDS
BOOK BY KIRK CAMERON AS YOU GROW
ARE BEING DENIED THE SAME STORY
AT PUBLIC LIBRARY'S ACROSS THE
NATION.
I'M NOT ONLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DOUBLE STANDARD BUT WERE TALKING
ABOUT KIDS AGES THREE TO NINE
YEARS OLD.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE DRAG
QUEENS.
IT'S SO MUCH AND PARENTS, WHY
CAN'T THEY CONTROL TO BE THE
PRIMARY DRIVERS OF WHAT THEIR
KIDS GET TO EXPERIENCE?
JACKIE: ABOUT APPEARANCE WANT TO
BE IN THE NOT COMFORTABLE WITH
IT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A CONVERSATION AT
THESE EVENTS YOU HAVE TO TAKING
ACCOUNT WILL HAPPEN IN FLORIDA
IT WAS BRANDED AS DON'T SAY GAY
BY THE BILL BY RON DESANTIS, IT
WASN'T ABOUT THAT I WASN'T ABOUT
GAY OR LESBIAN OR ANYTHING ELSE
IT WAS THE FACT THAT PARENTS
SHOULD HAVE INPUT ON THE
CURRICULUM OF WHAT THEIR
CHILDREN ARE LEARNING IN SCHOOL.
IN CHILDREN OF SMALL AGES SHOULD
NOT BE EXPOSED TO ANY KIND OF
SEXUAL EDUCATION REALLY BECAUSE
THEY'RE INFLUENCED, ABLE TO BE
INFLUENCED AT THAT AGE.
I KNOW A LOT OF PARENTS ARE
ANGRY ABOUT THIS SOME OF THEM
LEFT NEW YORK AND WENT TO
FLORIDA BUT THERE'S A LOT HERE
THAT HAVE THEIR KIDS IN PRIVATE
SCHOOLS AND THEY COMPLAIN ABOUT
IT EVERY DAY BUT THEY DON'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT UNTIL PARENTS
TAKE ACTION AS WELL AND BOYCOTT
SOME OF THE SCHOOLS OR THE
CURRICULUM A LITTLE BIT.
I KNOW IT'S HARD AND WHEN
PARENTS SPOKE ABOUT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS THEY GET CRUSHED FOR IT
AND THEY SAY THEY'RE AGAINST
CRITICAL RACE THEORY BUT PARENTS
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT THE
FIGHT OTHERWISE THIS IS A
SITUATION THAT THEIR KIDS ARE TO
BE AND THAT'S WITH A BE
LEARNING.
>> THIS IS KIRK CAMERON IS SUPER
NICE GUY THAT WROTE A BOOK, HE
TRIED TO GET SOME TIME TO TALK
ABOUT HIS BOOK AND READ THIS
BOOK BUT LOOK WHAT HAPPENED.
>> ONE PUBLIC LIBRARY SAID NO
YOU CANNOT READ YOUR BOOK IN OUR
LIBRARY BECAUSE WE ARE A QUEER
FRIENDLY LIBRARY IN OUR
MESSAGING DOESN'T ALIGN.
I'M THINKING WOULD LOVE,
KINDNESS, GENTLENESS, KIDS COULD
USE THE VALUES TODAY.
YOU THINK THEIR MESSAGING SHOULD
ALIGN WITH THOSE THINGS BUT
APPARENTLY THEY DON'T YOU SAID
YOU CAN FILL OUT A FORM AND
RESERVE SPACE BUT WE WILL NOT
RUN YOUR PROGRAM.
>> THE KEY PUBLIC LIBRARY THIS
IS SUPPOSED TO BE OPEN TO
EVERYONE SHOULD NOT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BUT I'M GOING TO
BRING UP SOMETHING THAT I
RECENTLY SAW NETFLIX DOCUMENTARY
WITH MEGHAN MARKLE AND PRINCE.
, HE SAID SOMETHING VERY
INTERESTING.
AS A DAD AND AS PARENTS I THINK
CONSENT IS A KEY PIECE TO THIS.
IF YOU HAVE CHILDREN IT SHOULD
BE YOUR CONSENT AS TO WHAT YOU
SHARE.
PRINCE HARRY ABSOLUTELY I THINK
A LOT OF PEOPLE AGREE WITH THAT,
SOME PEOPLE PICK THAT UP AND I
HAVE TO TELL YOU SOMEONE WHO IS
NOT MARRIED AND HOPES TO ONE DAY
GET MARRIED AND HAVE CHILDREN.
I'M REALLY DISCOURAGED BY WHAT I
SEE IN OUR SOCIETY, WHAT I SEE
OUR KIDS ARE LEARNING THESE DAYS
AND IT MAKES A LOT OF PEOPLE
FEEL VERY, VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
THAT YOU WILL BE ABLE TO CONTROL
WHAT THEY'RE TAKING IN BECAUSE
ISSUES LIKE SEX.
ONGOING 13 OR 14 IN SCHOOL AND
SOME BEFORE WITH MY PARENTS.
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO EXPOSE
KIDS TO THIS.
I WAS LOOKING AT THIS RESEARCH
STUDY IT IS THAT 44% OF
NONPARENT AGE 18 - 49 SAY
THEY'RE NOT LIKELY TO HAVE
CHILDREN.
I THINK SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE GOING ON IN OUR SOCIETY,
IT'S DEFINITELY LEADING PEOPLE
TO THAT.
TOMI: A PART OF THAT IS ALSO
PARENTS THAT WANT TO SPEAK UP
BUT THEY KNOW THAT THE MOMENT
THAT THEY DO THEY WILL BE CALLED
THE NAME AND GIVEN A LABEL.
IN FLORIDA MAYBE YOU'RE OKAY
WITH THAT BUT IF YOU'RE IN A BIG
CITY A BLUE CITY LIKE LOS
ANGELES OR NEW YORK CITY WHICH
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE DRAG
QUEEN STORY HOUR PERIODS WANT TO
SAY SOMETHING BUT THEY DON'T
WANT THEIR KIDS FRIENDS PARENTS
TO LOOK AT THEM AND SAY THAT
PERSON IS A BIGOT, THAT PERSON
IS INTOLERANT, THAT PERSON IS
ANTI-GAY.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH BEING
ANTI-GAY, ANTI-LGBT, HAS
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT THIS IS INAPPROPRIATE.
I'M ONLY 30 YEARS OLD BUT WE DID
NOT HAVE DRAG QUEEN STORY HOUR
WHEN I WAS IN ELEMENTARY WE DID
NOT LEARN ABOUT ANY